it sucks because I love JJ but hello reject Nation
all right we are here for bad batch episode
four I am Michael Tessler founder and CEO
of multi-house joining me today I'm not sure if
you've met him this is Greg doesn't have a title
Greg you excited for this episode I'm reasonably
excited yeah reasonably excited I don't even know
if we're recording I just kind of I think this is
the intro now this is the intro I think you should
tell them leave a like hey leave a like and uh if
you haven't already you should probably subscribe
and uh if you comment who knows I might comment
so do you know what I say about the patreon uh
you're yeah uh well first off uh super sexy
rejects uh go to the patreon or keep going on
the patreon if you haven't already uh there's
some great content full interviews some other
wonderful stuff you watch some pretty obscure
stuff like I see people in the comments all
the time like me watch attack of the titans just
Attack on Titan I don't know Attack of the Titans
starting James Cagney
Debbie Reynolds anyway so uh ready to dive in
some Star Wars all right let's roll that into it
God I hope we get to go to Tashi station
to pick up some power converters in this
episode faster harder better
faster stronger Roger Roger
this looks familiar oh I know
that guy he's always eating yes
oh I got you this time it's not Star
Wars unless you're playing the game
now you owe me two cartons of men's helmets
not so fast one more game rip her arms off
rip her arms off I got another job for you
Hunter and Echo back from the other Mission
yet oh transporting 50 cases of Nerf nuggets a
mission nor is it a proper use of us I want a
Nerf nugget you are gonna be my security what
is the mission zaphatoma can be a little rough
around the edges if you don't know what you're
doing got a little Sun Doula in the background
that's what I call Pottery pod
race pod race it's called Riot
racing it's called Riot racing in [__] oh my God
is it them the heads oh maybe the
announcers commentators and tear away
I hope they do that if it is I hope they do this
[Applause]
I think one of the chests one of thrawn
species was in the background there
I've never seen one it's a boss lady show
depressing well I love him I know this voice
not have enough information about this sport
to determine that at this time then take a
seat spectacled spectator all right all right
save it for the course it's alliteration I was
about to save it for the course excuse me I
can't talk right now it's time I prepare for
the next race what's up Ben Schwartz
is it is it I would watch a spin-off
artist citizens
gamorion that's Motley Crue thank you
oh you think your Droid can beat my champ
what's he saying get lost slimo let's see
what in The Phantom Menace is this episode
this is
you're using the batch to solve
your own personal vendettas
[Applause] [Music]
they had a version of this and Knights of
the Old Republic having flashbacks right now
jet space corn dogs from
the creators of Nerf nuggets
what is the protocols right doing driving
I swear that might be a chance why
would you want a front seat [Laughter]
knows what he is doing what's wrong with
this whole race is a death trap yeah
there's like nothing's happening so
they can't animate all this but
they can't afford inviting it
got a bad feeling about this [Music]
like the more cyberpunk Vibes yeah right
this is what Nascar should be oh
no not the Gumdrop buttons the speedo is in bad
shape but some of it is salvageable
that's the least amounts now goggles
give me some time I'm good for it that's not
how this works wanna step in here I
didn't bring you two for the company
punch him get him God he's like the alien from
Lilo and Stitch yes yes that's I couldn't pinpoint
it yeah how much does she owe more than you got
kid well what about Nerf nuggets we're not done
yet looks like you've done to me one last race
little Lanny we pay you doubles we win we get said
oh Sid's part of the family do
we have a deal we race tomorrow
and I keep sick as collateral God who's
that guy's voice I don't know but I love him
with a few more adjustments he may be
capable of racing uh that is hilarious
more than capable I am ready to where are
my arms that's what I wish jar jar had been
it's my kind of comic relief we should be taking
out that gangster this is not the first time she
has required our assistance due to her dealings
with individuals of questionable Integrity it
is a problematic pattern did you forget you're
working on me how about a little less chatter
a little more spanner nicely put I hope the
tail ends up as a permanent addition to the
bad badge I know it'd be nice it's nice having
the funny droids around yeah well there's none
so far in the show except for first season but
that was really sad Hustlers like us never change
sooner or later those outcasts you're hanging out
with will get to know the real sit I
might surprise you she's changed man
Omega has that effect on people and it's really
bugging me I can't pinpoint that guy's voice
hey it went down a little bit the food
yes I can
when I will not make twice I don't think a bite
was what is going on food is really confusing me
maybe it's a comfort thing it's just emotional
support sausage you are doing it calculations
won't help you it is all about strategy and
skill it would be wise to divert power to
the reflector Shields from your primary weapon
system oh an amateur mistake why Teo is your only
chance at Victory if you want to win out there
offense is the best oh my God what just happened
oh no
drugs what just happened
sophatoma is a danger
he's fine not out of it regret
nothing
looks like a forfeit no racer means Sid loses
tax season we have to do something
be the racer yeah yeah I've been wanting more
Tech you heard him that's still on I never stop a
fool from giving his life to make me I hope this
is how they kill off Tech yeah unceremoniously
oh if it's safe it's the trailer I want more
Tech [Music] [Applause] I gotta love the poses
oh that's cool
and finally tag
s [Laughter]
it's a comedian episode
us
so I love the mixed match
uh droids there that was fun
[Music]
oh this is exciting [Music] oh no they're so cute
what place is he in last but he's catching up
attack you gotta be in front to win [Laughter]
I love wrecker
[Music] come on
[Music]
yeah rave time yeah I want
to do some spice after this
did you just focus on not getting
blown up oh yeah got attacked [Music]
this episode's turning out
a lot better than I thought
it's learning to let go literally yeah
like Jean-Claude Van Damme kickboxer
camera love them
[Music]
awesome [Music]
did Mario Kart's way more fun than I remember
it's also the shortest time to attack fast enough
we call you Tech Deck around here yeah left Tech
attack
nice
oh my God it's so cramped in there [Music]
go buddy
ah man
I'm right there with you
oh man [Applause] [Music]
the Enterprise nice way done buddy
come on come on come on Tech Deck come on [Music]
let me sing hell yeah now this is
Padres I hope Tech leaves the batch
behind to pursue a lifetime career a
varieties ah I thought you were gonna
oh [Music] that's how I feel when people
talk about me in the comments cheers
we're square that was some recent goggles yeah
it's not Keith David who is that voice well
I guess I owe you one yes I would agree
I'll make it up to you I don't like the gun on the
bar hey you three oh you could have walked away
that loyalty is admirable watch your backs
watch your back watch your Watcher watch back
I feel like they just planted a really
important seed for this season [Music]
you know what I'm not gonna lie this show
every every time I'm like this is gonna be trash
this is gonna be a bad episode which I have said
begrudgingly before every single episode um
like we had character growth we had fun I mean
you and I were literally on the edge of our
seats well I'm gonna lie this episode sucked
laughs that was fun you know it I think it's it's
easy for episodes like this that are you know
it could be filler but like I feel like we
had great development particularly for Tech
uh I thought it was really it was also nice to
separate the bad batch a little bit and give
everybody some time to to breathe uh just like
watching The Chemistry Between wrecker and Tech
Ernie Hudson oh that makes so much sense
it was Ben Schwartz yeah okay I know
I hope you say Teo again but uh yeah no
I'm right there with you uh on the knock
on the live spectrum because this started off like
all right I guess we're back to some we gotta
fill out some episode numbers here don't we
get really engaging and really funny and exciting
and you know like with tech getting in the field
like everyone like in the first second episode
Tech got more [__] to do that was cool getting
him in the field and game shoot some [__] and
then here he gets to get behind the wheel and um
I haven't played High Republic you said no nights
we don't we don't talk about the Hiram yeah we do
higher Public's loved so is Picard season two and
one yeah but the the the the the situation with
tech was just so exciting and uh I thought it was
animated so well too like it was visceral and the
sound design is what got me like it's so upgraded
cyberpunk version of pod racing no I do that I
know I mean I I wasn't kidding when I said do you
want to do spice afterwards because like that's
the kind of like grungy like retro futuristic
Star Wars that I just like I love yeah I got an
Old Spice yeah we could put it on our armpits
later if you want it pulling out one though
you want to go home and rethink your life um
no it's uh dude it's just it it's so fun but
I got a conspiracy theory I think Sid is
gonna be our connective tissue to Maul and
all that fun stuff in the Star Wars underworld
wow that's a stretch uh I because because you know
it's ratchet you're right you know it's coming
though like like the question is from which angle
um you know and and I feel like setting sit up
is like way more ominous and making bad deals
with bad people I feel like that would be a really
interesting way to throw the bad batch into that
World um and like this time period for like Mall
in particular like this is like right when Death
Watch is and I've never read the comics like is
breaking him out um you know because you know
old palpi has him still um and uh you know and
watching him become more of a criminal element
uh and I just feel like that'd be really kind of
interesting to explore that side of the Galaxy
well I like to explore those things I have
a hard time believing it would be with Sid
I just maybe not Sid directly but like I think it
was Sid mission relationship puts them into that
criminal Circle so to speak fair enough because
yeah I think what they were saying with Sid was
something just a little bit more personal and
immediate like oh Sid might betray them but then
doesn't should make some type of more morally
righteous Choice when they don't expect her to
because they've been thinking maybe we shouldn't
trust it and they turn their back and then Sid
shows up and helps save them and so I was thinking
something more on those lines what they were
setting up I wasn't really going to like Darth
Maul hop skip jump here all right maybe it's not
mall but maybe it's the equally terrifying like
really threatening Star Wars villain Hondo anaka
you know it's like I just you know I I can't help
but feel like there is a connective tissue there
um it would as we get to the scarier
stuff she's how we explain snoke
all right conspiracy theory
she's Rey's real mother
it was all a cover-up Palpatine was trying to
protect her uh no it's it's uh yeah they'll be
something interesting there I'm actually
surprised we haven't seen uh Hondo or any
of the me too yeah I'm waiting for it every
episode I I'd like to I like to think that
um uh Jim Cummings uh Hondo's voice just
constantly text Dave filoni being like hey you up
um but this episode in particular was was the
kind of episode that I thought the comedy really
worked because it's easily is one of the sillier
episodes of the bad batch but sometimes the silly
ones in the first season were not my favorite
there was during growth there wasn't any yeah
there was no pulse to them they were kind of
bland silly like they were like uh maybe a
little kid would enjoy this but this is Bland uh
this was like the like a really family-friendly
episode and yeah I had a lot of jokes but to
me it was not every joke was Landing but it
really started to work for real I freaking just
like you have to go to the front to win yeah
and it's I thought Teo was great yeah it's not
always nice to see them do something different
with droids but that still feels authentic to
Star Wars because sometimes they miss the Mark
um Disney has made droids funny yeah which is
you know I it's one of the few things they've
been doing right yeah no that's that's true Phoebe
Waller Bridge so everyone would not stop raving
about Phoebe while in French yeah I know like k2so
ah no I I know I mean it's a this was nice because
it plays on a little bit of the Nostalgia I mean
like right from the get-go you're not shouting
pod racing at the same time and um they were like
everyone's gonna be shouting pod racing we didn't
clear up what this is very quickly uh no but
it was it was nice and uh I love any time that
you have that many background characters there's
just like I could re-watch an episode like this
clearly not for the plot but for just like the
Easter eggs and the little uh it was it was really
fun to see you know I mean even there was that
moment when we were going back and like almost
to the exact outfit it looked like Hera from
Rebels um I just like little things like that to
to catch you off guard and to keep it interesting
that I love well I enjoy Sid as well I think Sid
is the kind of character that well that wasn't
too appealed to in the beginning but you know
she actually cares about them she's just one she's
one of those characters kind of like have you seen
Gravity Falls yeah of course like Grunkle Stan
that's that's such a great where they're gonna
get you in trouble and put you into precarious
situations [Music] but they have a big part yeah
yeah I mean it's a fun character my
only problem is they just remind me
of everybody that I knew back home on Long
Island like it's just that kind of like
I don't know but I'm sure they like they
can tell you where the best bagel place
is you know yes so that's where that's what
they meant by Sid yeah I it probably is Hondo
huh it's probably not a ball and death watch
but maybe it is maybe it's connected is more
important than you realize yeah you know well
Sid's origin planet is dathomir is it no no
yeah no what I I could have you could have got off
holy [__] maybe he's right it's all connected uh
no uh it's actually Sid Sid was actually the
one that enslaved Chewie oh yeah that's wild
yeah we're gonna start spreading fake Star
Wars welcome to real rejects are number one
swords for fake Star Wars news I'm just
happy for Tech though yeah I mean me too
my only worry is that because we're spending
so much time with tech uh that the bad batch
I mean if they're gonna do what Rebels did every
season gets a little darker and a little grittier
and I wonder if we need to lose a member of
the bad batch in order to raise the stakes
um and I feel like Tech would be a the rest of
the team would very much be lost without him I
feel like the morning can get rid of his record
but wrecker's too funny you need you need that
or Echo if they kill Echo I'm out that one would
be so funny I'm gonna I will go through all that
all like oh it goes back and then they kill off
yeah like if they want to take another arm fine
but no not not Echo I I hope I hope you know
Echo being reunited with some of the other clones
um is gonna be so much fun but well I think
what's really neat about this one is this
season so far has been feeling like clone wars
in the sense of the first episode you're with
the batch if you don't see Crosshair and then
here the second episode's Crosshair you don't
see the protagonist at all and this one
there's no Hunter and there's no Echo
um right it gives yeah no it and it gives them
all time to breathe uh and more Focus yeah it's
nice which is you know and what a smart use of
Crosshair too like I not take I really didn't
care for Crosshair in season one what yeah I just
did like it the whole thing kind of fell flat on
me I feel like I didn't like them enough in the
subtle introduction of the bad batch to make
me feel like it was a devastating portrayal like
they were always kind of a bag of dicks you know
um but dude you should have saved that opinion
for when we got to the final episode yeah and
we didn't lose audience no listen I oh he's
a [__] badass don't get me wrong like no
but but you've done irreparable harm to the
damn have I have is this the end of the real
version sure John has made it to season two of
Clone Wars finally he's joining me now God man I
it is it is astounding that even like the one-off
episodes here like I went back and I was watching
season three of Clone Wars last night um and
you know it's fun it was I wanted to see Echo
um pre you know free body yeah we're not sure
what the pre-human center or whatever the heck
happened to him uh and like God even even on
its like off episodes the jump of Animation
audio engineering all of it is just like
it's mind bending it's it's just you know
um I feel like they threw down for here for bad
batch too the season two's looks so much better
yeah well I mean I think it's a a general
um there there is so much story but tell a
story patelling tangentiality there's story to
tell okay story but you don't even remember uh
no there's so much storytelling potential uh with
animation and I think that the um you know the the
historically speaking animation has been looked
down upon and has been kind of viewed as like
purely a children's medium and I feel like in
the last five years especially that's really
shifted on on the mainstream um and Clone Wars
I think had a big role to play in that uh and I
hope this means that they're going to keep doing
more animated series um because it's such a great
way to I mean is the bad batch of story that
needs to be told I don't know but I'm glad that
they're telling it and I feel like animation
is probably the best use of Studio resources
alrighty guys well the bad batch season two
episode four Tech Deck Pee Wee trick borders
I enjoyed this one Ben Schwartz keep him
around see if the headshot cross them over
let's get it done I want to see Teo in like
I want him to cut them in half and put them
on top of the bad Batch's ship and just half
a piece a sip Droid for now on uh well reject
Nation this was fun uh hey if if you think that
that's it that's it is the direct connection
to Maul uh and Death Watch comment below if
you think that I'm off my rocker and need to
stop watching Clone Wars at 3am uh also maybe
talk about that in the comments I'll respond
I swear [Music]